[Musique]
1er mai 1883 le tronçon de train entre
Versailles-Chantiers et Massy est
inauguré pour la première fois
140 ans plus tard l'inauguration est
célébrée par le passage d'un train
d'avant-guerre sur la ligne de la Grande
Ceinture de Paris avec des arrêts au
garde petitjouis les loges de la Bièvre
Dini et de Massy
aujourd'hui c'est un affrontement
l'association que je préside est affrêté
par un comité d'élus de la vallée de la
Bièvre pour effectivement commémorer les
140 ans de la Ligue du RER C ligne sur
laquelle nous circule aujourd'hui pour
nous c'est important ces anniversaires
là c'est comme hémoration et en plus la
note notre client after vient avec ses
administrés costumés costumes d'époque
avec nos voitures c'est c'est le mélange
rêvé en fait le train a accueilli plus
de 250 personnes à son bord pour un
voyage d'une heure 40 au programme
exposition photo retraçant les 140 ans
d'exploitation de la ligne musique
d'antan en live et collation au bar je
vous avoue que je suis ému je suis ému
en plus vraiment les il y a beaucoup de
gens il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
ont joué le jeu de des costumes donc
c'est vraiment on enfin moi je suis
revenu en 1930 quoi enfin avant guerre
et c'est très émouvant alors on a choisi
une tenue
raccord avec l'époque donc là on est
plutôt
191880 j'adore là en fait c'est génial
c'est magnifique
cet événement c'était l'occasion de
commémorer les 140 ans de la ligne mais
aussi de marquer le lancement d'un tout
nouveau projet la mise en circulation
d'une navette entre Versailles et Massy
la ligne C du RER sera déconnectée et
nous aurons une petite navette qui sera
plus régulière qui permettra aussi au
vélo d'entrer dans le train et nous
espérons que ce sera un outil de
développement touristique pour notre
territoire un projet qui verra le jour
en décembre 2023 suite à la mise en
service du Tram Train 12
[Musique]